TIMOTHY PEACOCK: Thanks for
joining us for Security 209,
Cloud posture and
workload protection
with Security Command
Center Premium.
I'm Timothy Peacock, a product
manager here at Google Cloud.
I look after our
threat-detection capabilities.
And in my spare time, I co-host
the "Cloud Security Podcast"
by Google.
I'll be joined today by
Dr. Jasyn Voshell, director
of product and solution
security at Zebra.
If you're interested
in learning how
to protect your organization's
use of Google Cloud
as a platform and protect
your workloads on top,
this session is for you.
We have a packed agenda
today-- an overview
of SCC Premium for those of you
new to the product, a deep dive
with our friend
Jasyn from Zebra,
and a lightning round
of announcements
from across the Security Command
Center platform, misconfig,
and threat-detection teams.
Let's dive right in.
Security Command Center
Premium brings together,
in one central tool,
security insights
across your organization and
across the security lifecycle.
I think of SCC Premium as
providing four pillars of value
for security teams.
First, asset and
resource tracking.
Staying current with resource
creation, update, and deletion
can be a challenge
in public clouds.
If you choose to give
engineering teams flexibility
in creating new services,
Security Command Center's Cloud
Asset Inventory makes it really
easy for organizational admins
to stay aware of what's
changing inside their org
and easily query for
deleted and changed assets.
Second, hardening.
Misconfiguration and
vulnerability detection.
Thanks to our real-time
asset updates,
SCC Premium provides real-time
misconfiguration detection.
Cloud Security Posture
Management, CSPM,
is a must-have for
security teams in Cloud.
Security Command Center Premium
provides "out of the box,"
actionable posture insights
for our top GCP services.
Understanding and responding
to misconfiguration exposure
is crucial for preventing
breach in Cloud.
The third pillar is
threat detection.
And we all know that despite our
best investments in hardening,
bad guys are still going
to try to do bad things.
I'll talk a lot more
about detecting threats
in just a minute.
Fourth and finally,
SCC Premium helps
you tie your success in Cloud
Security Posture Management
back to leading
compliance standards.
Not only do our findings
map to leading standards,
we also provide the right
tooling in the platform
to help you report
on your compliance
across your organization.
Now let's look in-depth
at two of these areas--
first hardening, and
then threat detection.
SCC Premium provides
"out of the box"
platform and workload hardening.
Our posture findings are, like
I said, generated in real time
and come with
remediation instructions,
making these insights
usable and actionable
by engineering teams
and project owners who
are maybe not security experts.
Above the infrastructure
layer, we're
now bringing in operating-system
vulnerability insights,
thanks to our partnership with
Google's VM Manager service.
Users can expect to see more
updates on SCC's presentation
of CVE detection from
a couple of other teams
from Google Cloud really soon.
Finally, on top of those
common vulnerability insights,
SCC Premium also
provides the same web-app
scanning for OWASP top
10 vulnerabilities,
as we use ourselves
in-house to protect Google.
Our web-security scanner is
even easier to use than ever,
with automated discovery and
scanning of your web apps.
All of this comes together to
help security teams proactively
secure both their cloud
environment and their workloads
running on top without bringing
in third-party dependencies,
exposures, and risk.
And with that, let's turn to
talking about the most unwanted
of third parties
with a quick look
at threat detection in Cloud.
A few years ago at
conferences, we all
got to feel very smart
and smug by saying,
oh, the cloud is just
someone else's computer.
The truth is, in Cloud,
there's a lot more than just
someone else's computer.
We have new planes
of attack surface,
and with them, new opportunities
for instrumentation.
At the same time as
the world of cloud
has brought tremendous
change to the security job,
our needs, as security
professionals,
haven't really
changed all that much.
We're still focused on
keeping data confidential,
guaranteeing integrity,
and ensuring availability.
Tolstoy wrote that,
quote, "All happy families
resemble one another.
Every unhappy family is
unhappy in its own way."
Today's major public clouds
are our proverbial unhappy
families.
Adversaries attack and pivot
through clouds differently.
And security teams need deep
cloud-specific expertise
to detect the most dangerous
threats in their environments.
With Security Command
Center Premium,
our customers get access to the
same real-time threat detection
as Google uses to protect
its own use of Google Cloud.
They say all models are
wrong, but some are useful.
Here, I offer what
is definitely wrong
but a hopefully useful,
six-layer model for thinking
about protect surface
in cloud environments.
SCC Premium offers
detection modules
at each layer of
this six-layer cake,
with special emphasis on
detecting identity compromise
and protecting Kubernetes
workloads at runtime.
We handle platform
threat detection
with our real-time
log-processing service, Event
Threat Detection, and
workload threat detection
with our Container
Threat Detection service.
We'll talk more about
some new capabilities
in both of those
services in just a bit.
With that, I want to welcome
our guest today, Dr. Jasyn
Voshell of Zebra Technologies.
Jasyn, thanks so much
for joining us today.
JASYN VOSHELL:
Thanks for having me.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK:
Tell our audience
a little bit about yourself,
your role in the org,
and what your company does.
JASYN VOSHELL: Absolutely.
So I'm Dr. Jasyn Voshell.
I'm the director for product
and solution security
for Zebra Technologies.
Zebra may be the
biggest smallest company
you've never heard of.
Everything from
scanning a package
to tracking an
asset from point A
to point B-- that's the
products we put out.
And my responsibility
and accountability
is to make sure those
products we put out
are as secure as possible.
A good example-- if
any of you have ever
gotten a package
delivered to you,
and it has a barcode on it,
that tracking from where
it was all the way to
arrives at your doorstep
was using Zebra Technologies
products and possibly solutions
as well.
And so my job is to, again,
make sure that everything
we do with that is as
secure as possible.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK: That's
an amazing impact
that a company like
that has so invisibly.
So they say to start secure
stories at the beginning.
So could you tell the
audience a little bit
about getting started with
Security Command Center
Premium, how long
that took, and what
it was like rolling it out to
your different business units?
JASYN VOSHELL: Yeah,
it did take some time.
I think with any new product
that comes into play,
there's always some
resistance at first.
People are used to doing
things a certain way.
But with the Google
Command Center,
we use a lot of GCP,
Google Cloud Platform,
in the solutions that we build.
The old ways of trying to
make sure that's secure,
the apps on top
of it are secure,
tracking the inventory
of what we have--
it took a little bit of time.
But as we progress
forward, it really helped.
Good example-- we
had a customer,
during an RFP-- a Request
for Proposal-- discussion.
And we were stepping through.
They were asking us, well,
how are you securing this?
How are you doing this?
And at one point,
we said, oh, we're
using the Google
Security Command Center
on top of this application.
And they stopped
and went, well, I
don't think we need to ask
the next 10 or 20 questions,
because they knew
about this product,
and they knew that
those questions
were being answered already.
And so with that, when that took
a hold, when customers started
to realize, yeah, you're using
that, our internal teams went,
that's a lot faster.
We can answer questions quicker.
We can make sure
the risk is reduced
or to an acceptable amount
where we need it to be.
And with that, we were able to
get better internal adoption.
You always want to carry
that big stick around,
but you never want to swing it.
You want the teams,
internally, to want to use it,
to show them the value.
And after a little bit of
that, getting over the hump,
having a customer go, yeah,
that makes it a lot easier,
having the sales
teams realize, hey,
you just answered an
RFP quicker on security
because you're
using this product--
they're happier about it, too.
We got a lot of--
quicker adoption much easier.
It also helped a great deal--
and I think we'll dive
into this a bit more
in a second-- but being able to
give those teams back feedback.
Hey, we found something, and
here's how you can go fix it,
and here's how quick
we gave it to you,
and not getting a lot of FUD
or a lot of cloudy stuff--
pun fully intended--
for those teams.
So that does help,
across the board.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK: Yeah,
so let's dive in on that,
because one of the
things that comes up
for me, with my
customers, is really,
how do they scale their
security operations as they
grow their cloud footprint?
One of the features
that we built--
really two things here--
to help address
that-- one is what
we call scoped or
delegated views of SCC,
where you can give the teams
responsible for a project
or folder a view of
their findings in SCC.
And the other is packing a
lot of detail and remediation
instructions into
the posture findings
so that non-expert teams
can really respond to them.
So how has it gone rolling
out that delegation
of posture issues to teams?
JASYN VOSHELL: Yeah, so I
don't know if anyone has had
the old-school
way of, how do I--
IT or some team finds a
bunch of vulnerabilities,
and they want to give that
to the engineering teams
and say, go fix it.
In the past, they might
have gotten a spreadsheet
or logged into a website.
And it's just a
plethora of data.
And anybody who looks at that
goes, like, my head hurts.
I forgot what happened.
And they kind of dismiss it.
With the Security
Command Center,
the ability to focus in on
this business unit for this
project--
so you're not looking
at every project,
just, hey, this business
unit, this project.
Here are the things we're
finding for you to go look at.
It cuts right to the chase.
And I think being able
to give those teams
or delegate to a certain
engineering team or security
team only what
they need to see--
They don't need
to see everything.
In fact, if they do, they're
looking at the squirrel,
trying to figure out
where it's going.
They can focus on
that, and they can
fix it a lot quicker, right?
It's not too overburdened.
So with that, it's helped
us speed up production,
in many cases, because
as we're moving--
we'll talk about shift
left in a second--
as we're moving that further
into the development lifecycle,
we're finding things quicker.
And we're only
showing the teams,
this is what you need to fix.
And so it feels a
lot quicker for them.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK:
Let's talk about shift
left, because we've got a
lot of different sessions
on shift left at
this year's Next.
We've got talks about
supply-chain security
and securing that.
Could you tell us
a little bit how
you see SCC's hardening work
supporting your organization's
shift-left efforts?
JASYN VOSHELL:
Yeah, so shift left,
for anyone who's not familiar--
hopefully everyone is--
it means putting security
earlier in the development
lifecycle.
So as you're even
dreaming about a product
that you want to build,
you're thinking security
almost upfront, right away.
And so this tool allows
us-- so as we stand up,
even at development, a
non-production instance,
we stand up GCP.
We put [INAUDIBLE] on top of it.
That Security Command
Center is still
scanning that, still taking
a real-time type of look
into what we're doing.
And we're able to fix
those items quicker.
And if anybody knows,
when you shift left--
because if I find a
vulnerability late in the game,
it's about to go out the
door, and suddenly I realize,
oh, no, the
foundation is cracked
on this house we already
built, it's a little late
to fix the foundation now.
Or if I'm going to fix it, it's
going to cost me quite a bit.
And so we really want to do
those things early on, or left,
in the process.
The Command Center allows us
to find those vulnerabilities
quickly, all during the process.
So we're not, like, moving 10
feet and then doing a check.
Every time we're
making a little move,
it's always checking
on us so we can say,
hey, we found something.
Oh, we'll take care
of that right away.
It helps to actually speed
up the development lifecycle
while keeping the
product secure.
And that's very
important for us.
It helps us get the
product out the door
quicker, which means
our customers have it
when they need it.
And that's the most
important for us.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK: That's
such a nice story
around both helping
with security
as well as helping with
development velocity.
So often, those are intention.
Could we also talk a
little bit about how
this is being used at your
organization for threat
detection and how that's
gone for your teams?
JASYN VOSHELL: Yeah, so one
of the nice things we like
to look at threat detection--
tons of tools in the world.
Everyone is going, oh, I can
find out what's going on here.
The hardest part, for me--
false positives.
You see something.
Hey, we think there's
a threat at the door.
Well, is it or is it not?
And if you're making
me put a resource on it
to go investigate it,
you're chewing up resources.
I can't expand my teams.
The Security Command
Center, in my opinion,
has driven that false-positive
rate down quite a bit.
[INAUDIBLE] with a
little bit of tuning
that we can do with the
help from Google to help
tune that as well.
So when we get an actual threat
or detection of a threat,
it feels more real.
We'll say, in the past,
you get a threat detection.
Maybe there's a 40%,
50%, 60% confidence.
When we see them now, through
the Security Command Center,
we're in the high 90s
on a confidence of,
yes, that is an actual threat.
It is actionable.
It's an event.
Let's go take care of that.
What does that naturally do?
It frees up our
resources to do things
that are more important,
more risk-adverse, as opposed
to chasing ghosts, chasing FUD.
So that helps us a
great deal, provides
confidence in the product.
It also helps us, even when
we're talking to our customers,
telling them, yes,
we're using this tool.
OK, what kind of things
are you looking for?
We look for this.
We're able to knock
things down quickly
and move to the next problem
or vulnerability or threat that
possibly comes up.
Also, getting to the
false-positive piece,
it does allow--
again, it frees up
those resources,
which means they
can go look at other things.
So as teams are
developing a project,
we're not chasing a ghost.
We're looking at real threats.
And we can get
back to looking at,
is there a misconfiguration?
Are we now aligned
with a benchmark?
Is there a standard
we're not aligned to?
And fix those things
to keep it hardened,
and not just chasing
things around.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK:
Oh, that's awesome.
I want to touch on one
area before we wrap up,
which is the user interface.
We've made a lot of changes
since some people started
using the product.
I understand you may have
seen the more recent versions.
We've got a lot of good
changes coming soon.
How is your team finding the UI?
JASYN VOSHELL:
Yeah, so you and I
have talked about this before.
I don't like to call it a UI.
I like to call it a UFI,
User Friendly Interface.
The ability for anyone
to just log in on a whim
and not have to crack open a
16-page or 160-page guide that
looks like some
major book and just
get to where you want to get
to is extremely important.
So as a director, I'm not in
the tool every day, right?
Our teams, our
SecOps division, is
in there looking at
what they need to do.
They're more advanced on it.
But when we have
something come up,
or leadership asks
a question on,
Jasyn, what's our
security posture?
What's our risk look like?
Or we have a customer
that says, we
would like to know a
little bit more about,
what are you doing with
your vulnerabilities?
How often do you see things?
As a director, I can
have the team open it up.
I can look inside.
And without really
knowing much more
than just my technical
space, I can figure out
what's going on in that
dashboard fairly quick.
And I've got to tell you,
that user-friendly interface
is very beneficial.
I, as a director,
can get an answer
really quick without
having to know
the technical details of it.
Now, of course,
there are some things
that that team is better for.
But from where I'm sitting,
I can get an answer quick.
I can tell our leadership,
our customers, or even
our internal people that
need those answers, even
from where I'm sitting.
So I'm very much
a fan of your UFI.
TIMOTHY PEACOCK: Jasyn,
I love that answer.
And with apologies to
directors of security
everywhere, I think
what we just heard
is that our user
interface is so easy, even
a director can use it.
Jasyn, thank you so much
for joining us today.
I really appreciate your
thoughts and insights
on the product.
We didn't want to leave
out your CISO, either.
He's got this to add.
And what I love
about his quote here
is that it really shows how SCC
Premium brings together both
the Cloud Security Posture
Management side as well
as the Cloud Workload
Protection capabilities
to give your company really
a one-stop shop for all
your needs in
protecting Google Cloud.
So I promised announcements,
and I didn't forget.
We've got a couple
of new capabilities
that are exciting
in the platform
as well as in the hardening
and threat-detection sides
of the house.
So with that, a couple of
really great announcements here.
The first one is that I've
had so many users ask me,
over the years, how
they can tune and manage
our systems that I suspect
security engineering is
actually full of musicians.
We're rolling out a
feature now that we're
calling Mute, which
is essentially
Gmail filters for
your SCC environment.
We know that not every
one of our findings
is always right for
your environment.
Organizations can have
compensating controls,
and threat intelligence
is occasionally noisy.
With the Mute feature, teams
can easily silence and control
the scope of those
silences to ensure
that their findings
queue is full of findings
that teams care about.
Muting would be really hard
to get right without finding
standardization.
And so we've
standardized attributes
across our different findings.
With Mute, we're simultaneously
rolling out new attributes
and making sure that our
vulnerability and threat
teams are using
those to give you
a consistent experience as you
go through the findings set.
We know that teams
already have workflows
for their other
security tooling.
And we're making
it easier than ever
to export SCC's findings
into your channels of choice,
including, now, your
Slack channels of choice.
Finally, a big ask from users
has been scoped or delegated
views.
Jasyn and I touched
on their value.
And using the normal IAM
patterns from Google Cloud,
teams can now give teams
responsible for projects
and folders insights
into the issues
happening in those environments.
On the misconfig and
vulnerability side,
we've got some really exciting
announcements as well.
Security Health Analytics, our
real-time posture-management
system, now supports
user-defined detection.
This has been a
top ask, and we're
really excited about
what's now possible.
I mentioned that we're bringing
in OS-level CVE detection
with our VM Manager integration.
This is a great collaboration
with our friends
over on Google Compute Engine
and will help organizations
to understand how
well they are doing
at the eternal
topic of patching.
It's a bit like flossing-- not
exciting, not necessarily fun,
but definitely among the
most important things
you can do to shift
your security outcomes.
Finally, on the misconfig
and hardening front,
we're also bringing
in detection of CVEs
in widely-deployed applications
with a managed deployment
of our open-source Tsunami tool.
Now, with that, on to the
threat-detection updates--
three areas in Event
Threat Detection and one
in Container Threat Detection.
Google Groups is used
by most organizations.
Rather than assign IAM
roles directly to users,
roles are assigned
to groups, and users
belong to those groups.
This makes management of
onboarding and offboarding
a lot easier, but there
are some gaps and risks
that get introduced
by Google Groups.
ETD has now integrated
with Google Groups
to give teams findings
that highlight
when a group with permissions
becomes more widely joinable,
as well as when a grant
is made to a group that
contains external members.
Additionally, we've
recently released
a set of detection techniques
using User Entity Behavioral
Analytics, or UEBA.
It's one of those acronyms that
only our friends at Gartner
could love.
But it describes the
general technique
of profiling and detecting
deviation from those profiles.
We're using it today to
detect account takeover
and compromise for
both IAM accounts
as well as service accounts.
On the Kubernetes side,
we're rolling out a number
of new detection modules.
One that we released
very recently
is a machine-learning-powered
bash-script classifier.
Our general theory
of defense with KTD
is to take away from adversaries
entire classes of technique
rather than specific procedures.
With this detector, we have
a robust and generic approach
to detecting malicious script
execution inside of containers.
It leverages Google's
strengths in ML,
and we're really
excited about how
it's performing against
production data already.
One more thing.
We've integrated
Security Command Center
Premium with Chronicle.
This is a wonderful
case of the teams
truly being better together.
SCC's real-time
threat detection joins
Chronicle's powerful
investigatory capabilities.
With this integration,
users can seamlessly
pivot from a [INAUDIBLE] detail
in Security Command Center
into a curated alert
view within Chronicle.
From there, users can
investigate the threat
and quickly pivot to
associated actions and events
related to the finding.
For example, imagine a SOC
operator quickly investigating
if a principal observed making
a suspicious IAM grant had
recent login activity or if they
made other suspicious changes
after that IAM grant.
We're really excited about
where this partnership is going.
Beyond ingesting SCC
findings, Chronicle
is also ingesting the stream of
Cloud audit logs in real time
and pulling Cloud Asset
Inventory metadata to ensure
that analysts have the
latest and greatest context
when investigating threats.
I know this has been
a whirlwind tour
of SCC Premium, our
capabilities, and what's new.
Thanks for hanging on.
If you're ready to learn more
or get started with SCC Premium,
you can check out our
detailed documentation
or contact your account
team to get started today.
We're here to protect
your organization,
and we're definitely
no use of you
if you can't follow
what's going on.
We take feedback on these
sessions really seriously,
so please do fill out the
feedback for the session
and let us know how we
could help you better.
With that, I want to
thank you for joining us
for Security 209, Cloud posture
and workload protection.
I'm Timothy Peacock, and
I want to thank you again
for taking the time to learn
about how Security Command
Center Premium could help
your organization with asset
visibility, misconfiguration
and vulnerability
management, threat detection,
and compliance reporting.
Have a great day.